d'église notre dame à dijon a été
profané des objets liturgiques ont été à
dégrader des hosties répondu par tous le
prêtre de la paroisse s'indigne d'autant
que ça n'est pas le premier acte de
malveillance
écoutez le cette église a été victime
d'une profanation c'est à dire que on
s'est attaqué à des symboles et des
lieux symboliques du symbolique de la
fois l'hôtel qui est ici qui était
dépouillé de tous ses ornements et là le
tabernacle où est conservé le pain
consacré cette année à la qualité ouvert
et le pain consacré le corps du christ a
été répandu partout dans l'église je
pense à ces départs une fois que ça
arrive dans une grande église de ville
dans une métropole comme dijon par
contre notre dame nous avons déjà été la
cible d'actes de malveillance il ya eu
il ya six mois à peu près un départ
d'incendié dans une chapelle
et puis il ya peu près trois semaines
une agression qui s'est passé dans la
sacristie